In Iraq, US President Donald Trump ordered a missile attack early Friday...
...that killed the head of Iran's elite Quds Force, General Qassem Soleimani,...
...at Baghdad International Airport.
In Iran, Supreme Leader Ayatollah Ali Khamenei appointed Major General Esmail Ghaani...
...as the new commander of the Revolutionary Guard's Quds Force...
...and warned of harsh retaliation against the US.
Navy ships are rescuing hundreds of people in Australia...
...who were forced to shelter on beaches because of wildfires.
In India, thousands of Muslims in New Delhi packed 17th century Mughal mosque of Jama Masjid...
...and raised slogans against the Citizenship Amendment Act after Friday prayers.
Finally from Lebanon, Japanese prosecutors are intensifying their investigation...
...into former Nissan Chairman Carlos Ghosn...
...while the international police organization Interpol...
...submitted a warrant for his arrest to Lebanese authorities.